j'ai vu cet homme qui saignait du nez
les oreilles enfin été sous la pluie
sans aucun secours enfin le quart de
flic est arrivé et ils l'ont embarqué
l'ont mis dans leur camionnette et ils
ont commencé à prendre les petites
mesures pour voir la distance ou
est-elle à la moto ou était en face à
l'infini c'est plus moi j'ai vu cet
homme je sentais qu'il allait mourir
qu'il est arrivé quelque chose de très
grave et je dis bon écoutez bondir mais
vous emmener le hac walchhofer m'a
répondu ta gueule et un de ses collègues
qui étaient sans doute beaucoup plus
courageux toute la bande est venu par
derrière et m'a donné un coup avec une
rare violence et je suis tombé la tempe
sur le sur le macadam de là je ne peux
plus raconter parce que j'ai eu un trou
total g j'ai fait du sport j'ai jamais
été nos quatre clubs se mettent arrivé
cette nuit voilà ce qui arrive quand on
veut porter secours aux gens à quoi on
m'a répondu je me mêler de ce qui me
regardait pas mais ce que je trouve que
ça me regarde et quand même